what's up bangbang lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right the beautiful intelligent plenty
of Mara Nova today I don't even know the
house drapes on do you take down the
drapes like a scallop okay I don't
understand you're right but you got your
sun's out guns out let's see them are
you ever gonna flex for us all right
lunch money is sponsored by black Phi
don't forget black Phi calm slash lunch
money
go deposit your crypto or your digital
dollars in turn up to eight point six
percent interest if you compare it to
traditional lending rates or deposit
rates at other places it dominates black
fine calm slash lunch money
speaking of banking what's going on with
the US banks u.s. banks are swimming in
money as deposits increased by two
trillion dollars amid the corona virus
they're swimmin
swimming because everybody's just not
spending their money for things happened
since January two trillion dollars in
deposits in April alone eight hundred
sixty five billion dollars has been
deposited in banks that is more in a
thirty day period than the highest ever
recorded in a single year previously why
first of all corporations were pulling
on their credit lines so Boeing Ford and
others started to pull on their credit
lines and get as much cash into their
bank as possible in case anything
happened the uncertainty forced them to
pull on those credit lines to is the
savings rate is up thirty three percent
the personal income rate is up ten point
five percent so far why is that because
the stimulus checks and the unemployment
is driving more cash into people's hands
so if you're on unemployment there's six
hundred dollars many people make more on
unemployment right now with the beefed
up insurance and then they do it their
jobs so they actually have higher income
the second thing is the savings rate
people aren't spending much of money
they're saving it at putting in the bank
at second reason the third thing is the
PPP money they took six hundred plus
billion dollars and they gave it to
small businesses one of the businesses
do they
really put it in their bank account so
that's where you see all the deposits
going up when Kumud first hit do you
think there were a lot of people who
went and pulled money out I did I know
that's why I asked anytime there's
uncertainty I pulled a lot of money out
in cash and was like look if this [ __ ]
falls cuz you all know what's going on
right and very quickly it was obvious
like hey this isn't a banking issue
that's not like the banks might go
insolvent but in the first couple of
days I was like I'm not taking any
chances
when got that cash baby get money get
paid what's up with in your head wait
and before deposit gains were
concentrated at the very top of the
industry JPMorgan Chase Bank American
Citigroup grew much faster than smaller
firms in the quarter obvious misleading
because those big firms just have more
clients right so everyone puts in the
same amount of money on a percentage
basis those guys just grow faster cuz
they're more clients okay what's going
on at the New York Fed so New York Fed
economists with the New York Federal
Reserve do not think Bitcoin is a new
kind of money and they said that it's
just another type of fiha yet oh baby oh
baby oh baby they so scared that now
they've come to this so first of all
define Fiat for the people fiat currency
is basically something that it's a
currency that's not backed by anything
right that's every currency of the world
right so the dollars will be if you
think of the dollar used to be backed by
gold right 1971 we went off the gold
standard and we got into fiat currencies
and now people can print as much as they
want right the New York Fed literally
has now stooped to the level of saying
Oh bitcoins just like the rest of us
they just forget this Bitcoin may be
money but it is not a new type of money
why are they saying this well so here's
what ends up happening right is what's
the saying they're like first they
ignore you then they laugh at you then
they fight you then you win right that
progression that's what we're seeing so
first of all no one wanted to to
acknowledge Bitcoin then they said oh
yeah Bitcoin that thing I heard of it
but it's not money now they're saying oh
it's money but it's not better for money
and eventually voters say bitcoin is
better so we're just seeing that
progression that you would naturally
expect you know New York Fed stop
printing the cash baby
okay well then they said that the
ability to make electronic exchanges
without a trusted party a defining
characteristic of Bitcoin is radically
new so they're admitting that some parts
of it are completely new and cannot be
compared to they're not admitting [ __ ]
it's an undeniable fact like this is why
I think it's so funny like this is
classic intellectual Olympics is you
literally have people who are like oh
those big corners they've been talking
about something for a decade we're gonna
write about it like as if it's new as if
like if we acknowledge it now all of a
sudden we're giving it credence like it
wasn't the fact whether you acknowledged
it or not now they're being forced to
that's the beauty of decentralized
technology is it is ultimately up to the
market to decide and the market is
deciding that Bitcoin ain't going
nowhere speaking of cryptocurrencies
what's going on with a coin alright so
you guys know akon akon all right
so young jeezy okay that's a song Hey
opening to a song please don't thank God
good he's 47 years old by the way that
has nothing to do with this sorry um
Akon has a new venture he is launching a
coin a cryptocurrency that will also be
the local currency in a con city a two
thousand acre development in Senegal
wait a second hold on hold on hold on I
think 2017 called and it wants its
headline back look first of all it
constantly G for putting together this
two thousand acre developing he's loaded
building a city well hold on a second so
supposedly the city's gonna be super
like quote futuristic right is gonna
have solar panels it's gonna have all
this stuff on infrastructure like he
really really want us to use technology
to make an impact the second piece of it
is that he's trying to actually go after
currency and part of the problem I heard
this my brother actually told me I don't
know business true or not but supposedly
Akon had a currency that is used in a
number of countries in Africa
I forget which countries he went and he
tried to exchange it at the air
or like the the currency exchangers and
they wouldn't accept it and he was like
he was like what the hell is that like
what do you mean this is accepted in
multiple countries but you guys won't
take it and then he realized wait a
second like digital currencies is this
new thing he's been an investor and held
bitcoins of 2014 that means I mean it's
doing pretty well probably yeah but the
whole idea here is he wants to create
this new currency a lot of people will
question why he had to create a new one
why don't you just use Bitcoin he
obviously my question why isn't he using
because he's gonna profit from it should
I get him on the podcast yes but is he
gonna I turned it down actually what a
coin on him him they asked me to bring
one of pockets I said no is it because
it's a coined no wait why I just I did
have enough time at the time I'll get
all email back all right it's finally
time I'll bring them back that's fine
but here's what's also crazy which I do
love econ was actually born in America
okay so the fact that like a lot he was
like oh he's going back home no he's not
he's just going to Senegal this do this
yeah that's what a lot of people were
arguing but basically the whole idea is
like he's super super innovative he
wants to use kind of his global
notoriety plus he's backed by a lot of
six billion dollars let me ask the most
obvious question that you are not
answering I thought we tried this whole
currency I'm gonna make a coin thing in
2017 and didn't work it doesn't work
okay so why is it happening again
because he's gonna try it again I don't
I by the way I don't think the eighth
coin part is interesting right like to
me he should just use Bitcoin right but
the city is what I'm interested in I
understand but I just feel like every
time somebody starts their own coin I
feel like there's some like nefarious
weird activity going o to be clear this
is all a business like literally he's
backed I think by a private equity shop
and it's like gonna cost to build the
city and everything it's gonna be like a
four to six billion dollar exercise
right so for two thousand acres or two
thousand acres isn't that much and so to
build this out is incredibly expensive
if it works they stand to make a
boatload of money right but I just I
don't think that necessarily we're gonna
see that craziness I'm glad a private
equity firm
involved um okay Satoshi didn't need a
private equity shop all right what's
going on micro transit alright so this
is really interesting so the LA metro
system put twenty nine million dollars
towards a partnership with ride Co to
subsidize transit uber just got a
three-year contract in Dallas Salt Lake
City and Birmingham are rolling out
their own experiments to basically
subsidize the transportation system in
cities post COBIT yeah I mean look if
you are a public transportation capital
allocator if you're a government
allocator and you're sitting there and
saying hey for every dollar we spend we
can get X impact but creating more
public transportation or for every
dollar we spend by partnering with these
folks we can get Y impact in some cases
not in all cases maybe not even in most
cases but in some cases spending the
money on partnerships and subsidization
for the private companies well actually
the better income and impact well there
are outcomes an impact then doing it for
public transportation especially now
that a lot of buses and subways aren't
running overnight or they're running
slowly or whatever alternate schedules
and they might not be clean and it might
not be clean I guess you would risk an
uber being cleaner I don't know but it
just it's more reliable right so it
would be nice to have an alternative to
a bus or a the dump the dollar amounts
are also small right so like there's not
there's probably not that much you can
do with three million dollars let's say
in Manhattan if you had three million
dollars and you're like okay improve
public transportation there's probably
not that much you can do with three
million meaning that most of the things
they're gonna have a material impact to
improve the experience or the efficiency
cost way more money than that three
million dollars to an uber in many of
these cities is likely actually to have
a pretty material impact so if you look
at like a lot of times when they do like
bond offerings and things like that it's
fifty a hundred million billions of
dollars like their their infrastructure
type investments so it cost a lot of
money if you only got three million
bucks again go back to that measurement
of if we put three million dollars into
these five scenarios which one has the
greatest impact yeah in some situations
that's going to be partnering with
private companies makes sense yeah in in
I mean that it's gonna be cheaper to get
an uber and lyft like there's gonna be a
standard price no oh really what might
happen is actually they just charge like
a one set fee well well actually hold on
let me think about this so I'm think
about it out loud but what they could do
is they could basically lower the prices
for you as the customer to incentivize
you to use uber rights with and even
have a car yeah well no but then what
they do is they say to the driver hey
you used to get paid $20 for this trip
we're only going to charge the customer
twelve to try to get them to come back
and start you an uber more but that
difference of eight dollars rather than
pass it on to the driver instead they'll
use the three million dollar
subsidization and uber will just give
the driver the difference so that the
driver still gets me they did a lot of
this early on that's how they grew
yeah I remember that right is basically
they would pay you and pay the driver so
literally in the cities they were like
hey if you come and you ride it's only
15 but we'll give it to you for eight
and then they would pay the driver uh
seventeen dollars for the ride and then
over time they just took away the
subsidies equations to improve their
fans it's just funny to me how cities
went so hard to try to ban over and lift
from its city and now it's like let's
partner innovation always wins baby okay
big fans love this story fake fans real
fans fake fans only the real ones so all
these are all these fans are sending
pictures or cardboard cutouts of
themselves for sports stadiums to put
cardboard cutouts of their faces as fans
and the seats because real fans can't be
there yeah this is weird to play in
stadiums without any people well I think
it's weirder to have like a bunch of
cardboard cutouts is so creepy
nah I mean look it this is like less to
do with what's actually happening on the
court or the field and much more to do
with no fans this is a great way to do
fan engagement right is hey send us a
selfie and we'll make you a cardboard
and we'll put it up in the stadium yes
then when then when all of a sudden it
comes back people feel much more
emotionally attached to the team because
they just participated but at the same
time like I don't think it actually
changes anything hold on a second are
the players wearing face masks says
play the games I don't think in I
haven't seen a single league that's
requiring them to wear face masks but I
think that they are required in some
leagues especially internationally to
wear face masks at the facility so you
gotta wear when you're walking around
stuff with when you get on the field
lead to get off okay right the other
thing that they're doing is in some
places I think the NBA they're going to
Disney role have you heard about this so
I don't remember all the details but the
NBA has decided that they're gonna send
all of the teams to Disney World and
they're gonna play the season there and
they're gonna run multiple games at the
same time on different courts it's
Mickey Mouse and Minnie Mouse but
they're gonna stay there they're gonna
do all this stuff and so one of the
things is they're talking about if they
decided to do it or not
is they're gonna pipe in fan noise over
the speakers are gonna play like it's a
normal game maybe sitcoms you just hear
the fake laugh and get it oh I don't
think there's be laugh tracks I think
there's gonna be fan noise like imagine
if every time in our house when when you
crack the joke and no one laughs there
was a laugh track I could just do it on
the TV
yeah no guys fun fact now every time I
do something he doesn't like her he does
something I don't like the threat has
become i'll tell the people on lunch
money what you did I'm perfect I don't
do anything wrong by the way anyone keep
it tracking home we played chess four
times the other night I went three for
four you won that game in a game of luck
but the game of skill chess for games
you won one yeah I was I was mad that I
didn't defeat it yes you're right you
got smoked it was a crime literally I
thought that the ambulance was gonna
show off okay massacred these feelings
do not get hurt unless you beat him in
chess then it's like a freaking baby no
I'm not I'm not good at chess everyone's
clear you're not good at sir no the only
person I can beat is Polina and I
destroy her what time I told her I
wasn't going to sleep so I beat her ten
times in a row yeah it's an interesting
time here in this apartment yeah you're
you've lost so much at chess
I don't even know which direction is up
anymore because all you're doing is
going down
about two nights ago when I beat you at
backgammon and chest back-to-back I did
you said it on the show that did you see
Bruce's champions we got bad short-term
memory now that didn't happen if I don't
remember it it didn't happen never
forget that's a life lesson for all you
there by the way having Father's Day to
all the father's watching this best
piece of advice my father ever gave me
anything worth doing in life is worth
overdoing
think about that name something that's
worth doing this not worth overdoing
eating know if you ever have started
eating and like it then keep eating it's
good for you no problem what else okay
we're done here what else you have
turned to the trash again I know cuz I'm
blocking your [ __ ]
alright guys we got a lunch money winner
I already forgot who it is hold on shady
yeah I forgot the O'Shea d750 - I'm not
gonna say what your full email addresses
but shady 750 - you won I've sent you an
email response I could send you your
$100 dolla dolla bills y'all what's up
y'all
what do you know alright guys that's it
for lunch money today well Wall Street's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get a lunch money right
hopefully you're enjoying this show see
you tomorrow don't make me flex my guns
bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did don't
forget lunch money's now sponsored by
black 5 so go check them out there's a
link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
black fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina they've got 3 products
they can give you a US dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account
go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6% it's
pretty compelling so click on the link
in the description say thanks to the
folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy plane in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends